قادمون من جهات اربع
ينسق الرسو هجماتهم في الشرق الاوكراني
على ليمان وبخمت ومارينكا
في وقت واحد لكن غايتهم الكبرى تبقى ضخمه
من الاهداف ذات الاولويه للعدو خلال هذا
اليوم تعرضت مناطقها لمئه وسبعين قذيفه
مدفعيه وصاروخيه عدد الهجمات في باخمه
انخفض بشكل طفيف ويجب ان تؤخذ في الاعتبار
عوامل عده معقده وظروف المناخ ومحاولات
اعاده تجميع قوات العدو
يقول الطرف الاوكراني ان الروس لا يحققون
اي تقدم يذكر على الجبهه الشرقيه ويقول
الشيء ذاته عن خرسون جنوبا حيث يستمر
القصف الروسي كثيفا على المقاطعه لن تشير
موسكو بالطبع الى ما يعترضها من عقبات
لتحقيق اهداف ما تسميها عمليتها العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا لكنها لا تخفي الحاجه
لتحسين كفاءه النظام اللوجستي لتزويد
قواتها بالضروري من الاسلحه والذخائر
تحققت خلال الاسبوع الجاري من استفاء
مؤسسات المجمع الصناعي العسكري لانتاج
الذخائر التي طلبتها وزاره الدفاع ونظرا
لتوسيع القدرات الانتاجيه وزياده انتاجيه
العماله فقد زاد عدد المنتجات المصنعه من
قبلهم لدعم القوات مرات عده الحديث يدور
عن عده انواع من الاسلحه التقليديه وعاليه
الدقه تعرضت وزارته في الشهور الماضيه
لانتقادات حاده من اشد المدافعين عن الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا لعدم توفير ذخيره
كافيه للقوات على خط المواجهه لكن زياده
امدادات الذخيره وانتاج الذخائر عاليه
الدقه قد يفسرها حلفائك باوقات عصيبه يمر
بها الروس في اوكرانيا
يقرا الامريكيون في ذلك وغيره من معطيات
الميدان فشل استراتيجيا وعمليا لموسكو لكن
الرئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه
يستدرك
الجنرال مارك مالي استبعد نجاح القوات
الاوكرانيه في طرد جميع القوات الروسيه من
اراضيها هذا العام ماذا بقي اذا لهجوم
الربيع المضاد الذي طالما لوح به
الاوكرانيون
يعتقد البانتاجون ان اخراج القوات الروسيه
من اوكرانيا مهمه عسكريه صعبه للغايه
لكنها ليست مستحيله اما ما قد يقتضيه
الامر من وجهه نظر امريكيه فضرب
الاوكرانيين مقر اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في شبه جزيره القرم تقول كييف ان
الاسطوله عزز تشكيل سفنه اخيرا مما يجعل
التهديد بتوجيه ضربه صاروخيه مرتفعا
للغايه